hello i'm alvin welcome back to tasties
making a big the show where i make giant
versions of some of america's
most beloved foods today i'm going to be
making
a huge hot dog how are we going to do it
i'm not so sure yet but we're going to
find out right now
okay so you can't make a hot dog without
making a
hold on so you can't make a hot dog
without making a
hot dog so we're gonna make a hot dog we
have a kitchenaid mixer with a
meat grinder attachment all the parts
have been frozen to keep
everything nice and chilled if it warms
up things start to stick get messy and
that's not good
over here i have a lot of chuck which is
a nice cut of beef with a lot of fat and
flavor
i've never made a giant hot dog before
let alone a
regular hot dog so i'm gonna make a hot
dog
make sure that this doesn't get stuck i
want to do one piece
at a time and you go
where'd you go dude i put him in but
he's not coming out
so we gotta put in another one come on
man
slowly oh i can hear this guy working
really hard
if you remember my friend todd here from
the mac and cheese episode
had a little bit of a medical accident
where smoke was coming out
since then he's been a long time in the
er and he might be sent back to the
hospital in a little bit
all right now it's slowly working whoa
whoa whoa
calm down now so i figured out that
grinding of that beef would have taken
us probably like two days with that
you know old machine so i went out to
the store got some ground beef the
butchers are way better
than i am and doing that kind of stuff
because you know as a wise poet once
said
ain't nobody got time for that grinding
isn't enough hot dogs are smooth they're
not burgers
that requires some additional processing
oh yeah
look at this guy and to turn the mixture
into more of a smooth
emulsified paste i'm adding a little bit
of ice water to help
it maintain its structure
delicious i want to say this batch is
done for now see what we got wow that
really is
fresh hot dog stuff oh
that smell is something else i
would weak i would have processed the
second batch and you know y'all don't
need any more details about that i want
to do that and you guys just
just chill out for a couple seconds
there are certain seasonings that make
hot dogs taste like hot dogs so we have
salt sugar garlic and onion powder dry
marjoram
dried coriander smoked paprika sweet
paprika
white pepper mustard powder mace
the spice not the self-defense weapon
and
last sodium nitrate which is a curing
salt that gives the hot dog
its signature pink red color after it's
cooked
oh boy this is a lot of seasoning the
one thing i will say is that
it now smells a lot better so this
meat mixture has now been completely
seasoned we have a
large sausage casing that we purchased
from the bologna company
so i have a strong hunch so they know
what they're doing
in order for us to make a hot dog with
it it does need to hydrate a little bit
so i'm putting it in warm water so it
can become nice
and stretchy and flexible so we can put
the meat inside of it
and this will take about 30 minutes this
is really weird it's like a giant chili
pepper
how do you open this guy like like
no the goal is to get all of this meat
inside this casing this is going to be a
very weird process
hold on this kind of feels like when
you're filling up a pastry bag for like
piping frosting so
let's just think of it that way oh no
get you better not oh my god i swear to
god dude
are you kidding me you are kidding me
good thing this table is clean
okay so this is what it looks like when
all that meat
uh was put in the casing i'm gonna need
to tie it so i want to get a
nice twist going on see if i can tie
this guy
okay i think it's time to cook it good
job dude
we have a nice water bath to help it
cook slowly
and gently if i had kids this is how i
would lay them to sleep
not not in a water bath that's that's
that's that's bad
all right come on dude oh boy
[Music]
come on in you go this guy's in the oven
gonna cook for around two hours to
slowly
slowly cook it through the water bath
and then we'll check back
so our friend todd is back to make the
hot dog bun
from scratch so to start i'm combining
some
warm milk some sugar and the yeast so
that the yeast
has plenty of food this is a recipe that
is directly from
joshua weissman he has some great stuff
on youtube so be sure to check him out
because his recipes are really good
all right oh and i spilled classic alvin
okay
this is gonna chill out until it starts
to get nice and bubbly into the mixer
i'm adding some bread flour don't spill
here i spilled
okay and some salt just gonna
incorporate this a little bit
todd has seen some stuff it took me a
while to coax him back out to come back
out for another round but
we're gonna get every ounce of power out
of this guy before he
needs to go to the scrap yard that's
kind of dark
[Music]
okay so the yeast has grown up a little
bit
as you can see this is pretty much ready
to go
coming together to make this dough even
richer and nicer i have two eggs and two
egg yolks that i'm just gonna add
todd i'm sorry i'm gonna have to kick it
up a notch for you
let's make the dough extra soft supple
and rich i'm gonna go slowly with a
couple of tablespoons of butter
this is where the real battle begins
hang in there i got four more
tablespoons of butter coming i can't
come out
keep going never give up okay i think
the dough is done
all right take a long rest buddy
nice i'm gonna shape this guy into a
nice
pillowy ball this dough feels so nice
oh my god so it's been 45 minutes since
this bread has been resting
he's grown quite a lot as you can see
and this dough has so many air bubbles
it's so light it's super fluffy
so i'm going to punch it down wow that's
fun look at all
that gluten development that's what i'd
like to see
come on come on look at that
trying to shape it into a hot dog bun
shape so i'm
again sort of tucking and rolling
kind of looks like a baby i don't want
to name you though because
probably get attached and then i have to
like cut in half for the hot dog
oh name i'll just call you baby okay
let's put you in your little
foil crib i don't know how to hold
children
that's not how you should treat children
at all so this
is gonna proof for another 45 minutes or
so before it bakes and then right before
it bakes i'm gonna brush some egg
on top of it to give it some really nice
color into the oven you go big dude
goodbye
the hot dog's been cooked in that water
bath
and cooled that was fun that was like in
kindergarten
look at that it smells really good like
a really really seasoned
beef thing to get the really nice color
it deserves we're going to help it by
making a little bit of a glaze
i'm going to put in some barbecue sauce
some
ketchup and a little bit of oil
let's brush this dude time to paint
nice i'm bob ross i'm currently painting
with
a deep shade of hot dog red there are no
mistakes
just happy little accidents i'm very bad
at art
but i can brush hot dogs over soft buns
any day i'm gonna put this into an oven
so that
the glaze can sort of caramelize and
cook and bind with the sausage
and i will be right back big boy
okay we have a wonderful hot dog-esque
giant tray that was made by our art team
i think it's fantastic and this is what
we're gonna serve the hot dog in first
things first let's get the bun
in there all we're gonna do is we're
gonna split the bun down the middle
don't mess this up alvin
[Music]
slow and steady okay how am i gonna get
you
all the way in there guess we just gotta
go for it
houston we have landed that's not what
they say right houston
usually they say houston we have a
problem but there are no problems
in houston i mean new york can't have a
hot dog without ketchup
mustard let's draw some squiggles
[Music]
i think that's okay so oh [ __ ]
maybe i should have done that
i think it did it looks like a dna helix
but that's okay
i think this is a giant hot dog i'm very
happy with it it's pretty heavy i want
to say like 20 pounds
this hot dog is the size and weight of
at least
80 hot dogs it looks pretty good time to
eat it
oh it's really soft and tender whoa
look at that wow look at that color
this is my portion a nice sausage meat
patty with two
nice bread croutons
that's a lot better than i thought it
was gonna be still tastes like a hot dog
but it's like a fancy
sausage meatball thing to be fair
everything here was made from scratch
there's none of those preservatives
those artificial flavorings maybe that's
why it doesn't taste as
nostalgic but i will say pretty darn
good hot dog
so you guys are probably wondering
what's gonna happen to the rest of this
i would have personally loved to share
this with friends because that's
something i like to do
but unfortunately i can't do that right
now so me and this hot dog gonna spend
some really good quality time together
and i will see you guys next time it's
just you and me dude
[Music]
you